in terms of the partnership between ttsa
and the government there was i didn't
actually see this but according to my
friend mick west he says j.j abrams ufo
documentary episode 3 suggests ttsa
might be part of a government
disinformation program that's what i
signed up for i was like how do i lie to
my friends and my family
can i just comment on that first of all
you know that's that's rather insulting
it's insulting you know not only to me
and you know and all the people that
work for the government what have you
you can't have a disinformation program
in the government
it's illegal
you can't do that um i wouldn't do that
personally i mean i i that's just that's
terrible and and you know you cannot
influence the population of the united
states that you government governments
can't do that it's called an operation
and you can't have that
uh it's it's not we we don't do that and
um uh as a matter of fact you know it's
one of the reasons i don't like going on
shows
uh because when people come up with
these questions you know you sort of sit
there and you look at them and say well
if you really knew how the government
worked
um you know when i was in cia i mean you
know when i was in the senior service at
one point i was running rather large
programs
i had lawyers all around me i mean you
couldn't make a decision without making
sure that you were right on the money
and we
say i in particular it's a great
organization i mean they made a lot of
mistakes in the past but by and large
it's a very very straight-laced
organization you do not do anything uh
that would in any way harm a u.s citizen
or uh or uh or the population in general
so
that's bogus yeah i know okay and i
appreciate that so much and believe me
you know and no one has more respect
that didn't serve at least than me i
mean my mystery
yeah
but i think i do want to say you know i
mean one thing just to criticize um the
government that i do love and support
and that's the best country on earth
i'll say that
except maybe canada kurt's gonna speak
up about the the 51st state to the north
up there but anyway uh in all
seriousness you know i look at kova 19
and i look at you know the trillions of
dollars that go from our 16 of our
entire budget goes to the military cia
fbi all these nsa we didn't i remember
going to dinner in 2020 in january 2020
my friend told me you just got an
invitation to go to china are you going
to go brian i said i don't know and he
said you shouldn't go because china's
building this hospital slash prison
they're gonna start locking people in
because this thing called covet i said
okay well i'll keep my eye on it i'm not
gonna go to i'm not not rushed to go to
tibet anyway i'd love to go someday but
uh but they knew about it my friend at
dinner knew about it in other words jim
and trillions of dollars of and the
countless lives that were lost precious
individual lives lost in america because
you know and you think with this huge
apparatus uh that they'd be capable of
doing something preventing something and
i don't want to get into politics i i
hate politics and that's why i'm an
astronomer because there's no democratic
comet there's no republican asteroid
right so talk about the government like
could they do could they cover up
something like this could they do it
malevolently as you're saying the cia's
basically let's just call it what it is
you're saying they're they're comprised
of good people good men and women honest
patriots um how come they weren't on top
of something like covid which was you
know known to my dinner party guests
well you know
let me just say this uh the last 10
years
i consulted with the intelligence
community and i was working on uh
counter biological weapons uh and one of
the uh corollaries of that was you know
working on pandemics and talking about
pandemics i can't tell you how many
meetings i sat in with the government
from people that did nothing
but talk about the coming pandemic cia
has written intelligence assessments on
it so has dia
i mean almost every government agency
has come out and warned
people that this is going to be
happening down the road and it's just a
question of
when but the problem with this is um
nobody listens the government does not
listen congress doesn't listen and the
senate doesn't listen until it happens
and when it happens they jump up on the
air start pointing fingers it's it's a
shame it really truly is 9 11 was the
same way we were screaming you know
bloody murder about uh you know about
osama bin laden this is this is what's
going to happen and we think this is
going to happen soon and people just
look at it and you know say well i don't
really believe it could happen right but
um no in many i mean there are a lot of
times where the intelligence community
fails but but a lot of these no we were
not we were right on top of all this
early on
but nobody wanted to spend money
billions of dollars creating
uh say a a a you know a a vaccine that
that could you know help you know
something when when there wasn't one
where there wasn't a when there wasn't a
pathogen out there yet so
and you know the government budgets i
mean like we can have a whole program on
on government budget and how money is
spent and it's usually spent on
quarterly things the things that you
absolutely have to do so anything that's
looking in the future
like uaps by the way you know low
probability high impact events like that
they don't get the kind of
attention they deserve
but you're right i agree with you mm-hmm
you want to ask
some of your viewers questions yeah well
about the government not
participating in disinformation i'm
curious there's
mk ultra project mockingbird or
operation mockingbird and project blue
book and quite a few others so what do
you make of that and also even if it is
illegal it's not as if the government
hasn't done what's illegal before
oh no no the government has
oh absolutely i'm not making excuses for
the government i mean the government
has done some terrible things it wasn't
until 1977
for instance when the cia was was held
held accountable is really when all that
stopped when mk ultra came out and and
and um i can't remember the name of the
commission but it was uh gerald ford was
running it and uh uh it
uh
actually gave presentations on it i
don't know why it's slipping my mind
right now but but essentially a ramparts
magazine had a big article on this and
and the and the intelligence community
just changed right there i mean
mk ultra was a program
you know they were experimenting with
you know with with hallucinogenics
because they thought they'd control
people's minds because they knew that
the russians were experimenting with it
so they were doing it
it was a terrible terrible program um
and it was an awful program people died
but you know and then they burned all
the files so we don't know what the hell
happened uh
and and this this has gone on through
you know
throughout the government and very
beginnings but as the government gets
older and as we learn from these
mistakes things really do get better um
uh so yeah i mean when you look at like
the condon report that was a it was a
total whitewash
total whitewash
and
and they basically came out and said you
know we're just gonna we're just gonna
make fun of people who believe in uaps
and ufos and all this kind of stuff and
that was awful they shouldn't have done
that
uh and it was actually one of the
reasons why
a lot of us in this
these unofficial government workers
decided we're going to go out we're
going to take this private
and i we told the highest levels of
government that's what we're going to be
doing
because they can't seem to get this out
i don't know why that talks with them
but they can't get it out and none of
them had any issues with us doing this
they didn't have any issues with tom i
mean it was just go ahead go ahead and
keep us posted
if you want you know and we do
we do and if we ever come across
information we'll share it with them um
you know we're not
anti-government by any stretch of the
imagination but we certainly don't show
for them and we certainly don't work